We just ate a
It's
like so well I um you know I didn't go
to staple curious why do you do
something oh why I stapled them
together
session because thick as I can have it
before I can no longer say together that
is
exactly there there's not some grand
organization
Just a reminder in case you haven't
started started working on your
valuation. It's time to get started. So,
you know, spring break is coming. You
haven't even picked a company. I know
you're one of these days. No, you know
what? Once you get towards April and
you're graduating on May 9th, 10th,
things are going to get really difficult
to do. So, get it done before that
moment hits, right? So, premature
graduation is the last thing you want to
be fighting. And uh so get that at least
that feedback thing because that's most
of the project actually if you can get
that DCF to me on April 4th. We got the
bulk of the project done. There's a
pricing section but that's really kind
of topping off section. So today is one
of my favorite sessions in this class
and you're going to see quickly why that
is because it's about connecting stories
to numbers. It's the title of one of my
books. It's actually I'll talk about you
know at the start of the class I talked
about how I came to that recognition
that you can't value companies without
telling a story and you know how
difficult it is to get that idea across
especially among numbers driven people
know sometimes you know I'll get I mean
I remember right after I wrote the book
I was you know the I was giving this
talk at a banker's conference and the
banker said this story thing it's all
fuzzy you're making biased judgments I
don't work with stories I just work with
numbers so I asked him to give him one
of my D one of his DCF valuations and I
took his DCF valuation and took his
valuation and read back the story I saw
in the valuation. So I'm going to make
you play that game. Let's suppose I'm a
numbers guy. I show you a discounted
cash flow valuation and I'm going to go
give you the inputs that I used and from
the inputs I want you to reverse
engineer the story. So I've estimated a
compounded annual growth rate of 50% a
year for the next 10 years. Right?
I'm estimating an operating margin of
20%. And you compare to the industry
average, it's twice as high as the
industry average. The company's
reinvesting very little. It's a high
sales to capital ratio, reinvesting very
little. And its cost to capital is much
lower than that of the average company.
You have the histogram there. So all you
see are the numbers. I want you to
reverse engineer from these numbers what
the underlying story is. First, can you
guess the company size based on the
numbers? Is this company that this guy's
valuing or this person is valuing small
or large? It's small. Better be small,
right? Because he's saying a trillion
dollar company and doing this, he's
going off into fairy tale. It's probably
small. And what's the clue that give
makes it small? The 50% annual growth
rate. 50% compounded over 10 years is
making your company 100 times bigger
than it is today in terms of revenues.
That's a terrifying. If you have a
million in revenues, you can pull it
out. But a billion. No, that's going to
be much more difficult. Is there some
implicit story about the total market?
Is it you think stable or
growing? If it's stable, how does the
growth come? You come from fighting for
market share, right? Implicit in the
story is there's not much fighting
because you're increasing and your
margins are going up. So whether the
analyst tells you or not, the market
better be growing. If it's a stable
market, we have a problem with the
story.
Are you learning something about the
competitive advantages this company has?
What are the numbers that kind
of want to try with you? Strong or weak
based on those
numbers? Leon, you want to try?
And the reinvestment rate is not going
to tell because that's a choice by the
company. So, what are the things you
look at to see if you have a strong
competitive advantage? You're going to
look at the margin twice aside. There's
something that's driving it. either a
brand name or something that's and
finally is there anything you can look
at in these numbers that'll tell you
something about the capital intensity of
the business what what do you think low
capital intensity high capital
intensity and you sounded like you were
guessing so I'm going to push you on
this what what part of that story makes
you're right it it is low but what what
part of the story gives that
away investment low reinvestment right
capital intensive businesses to Oh, you
need to reinvest more. And can you guess
something about the nature of the
product? Is it discretionary,
nondiscretionary? Where? No.
Again, you have 50/50 shot. I'll help
you out. Discretionary,
non-discretionary. Discretionary. Try
again.
Margaret, you want to you want to help
out? What What part of the inputs will
tell you whether it's discretionary or
non-discretionary?
I guess we're non-discretionary because
the KAR goes 50%. Look at the the number
that's going to give you away is no
margin is brand name.
The cost of capital. Remember we talked
about basis. What keeps the bait of a
company low? You provide
non-discretionary product. You're a
grocery store. You're going to have a
lower beta than if you're Whole Foods.
The cost of capital is low. So what he's
telling is a story about a small company
in a growing total market with strong
competitive
advantages, a very non-discretionary
product and low capital intensity. So
you read the story back and say do you
buy the
story? And if the banker says look that
is the story I was trying to tell, we're
settled. But if you say that's not the
story I want, then you know you change
the numbers. So, one thing we're going
to talk about today is how every time
you use a number for a company, whether
you like it or not, you're telling a
story for the company. And you got to
stop and ask yourself, do I believe my
own story before you show it to other
people? Each of you has a company. As
you sit down to value, you'll have a
spreadsheet, but you're also
simultaneously developing a story. I
want you to make that story explicit.
So, let's say you've told that story.
Who you
val? Reddit. That's right, man. So,
what's the story you would tell for this
company?
They're uh they're not profitable. Now,
before we do that, what business are
they in? How do they make money? Ads.
Ads. It's an online advertising company.
The more people that get on Reddit, the
more money you make. Okay. So, you need
people on the platform. And not just
more people, but you need them to stay
on the platform. That's what Facebook
versus Twitter showed us, right?
Facebook is a more valuable online
advertising platform because you come
and you hang out. The average person on
Facebook spends 57 minutes a day. That
includes Facebook, Instagram, WhatsApp.
It's worth So the story here is not only
about how many people go on Reddit, how
long do they stay? Do you spend a lot of
time on Reddit? You can admit to it if
you can. It's not a bad thing. But the
question is, you know, there are that
draws a subset of people who essentially
are drawn to those Reddit discussion
boards that basically there might be
topics of interest to them. It's an so
is it what what's the total market is a
total advertising market, right? 10
years ago, online advertising was a
small part of this market and it was
growing not because advertising overall
the advertising market overall can't
grow very much. Why not?
Where does the money come from? It comes
from companies spending on advertising.
It's a cost item. So if advertising
grows 20% a year, everybody's going to
go bankrupt along the way, right? So the
total advertising market is a pretty
mature market. Online advertising was
growing because it was a small part of
the market and it was essentially
disrupting newspaper advertising. But
those days are done. Right? Today,
online advertising is about 2/3 of the
overall advertising
market. And characterize the market
more. It's a market that's 2/3 with two
giants which are Facebook and Google,
right? The question is where does Reddit
fit in there? I mean, is it going to go
after Facebook? Do you think it'll get
as big as Facebook? No, it's not that.
It's a niche business, but there's
enough money there. And essentially,
you're saying, what is that niche going
to be? How big is it going to be? That's
your story. You're saying that's the
story that's going to drive your revenue
growth. It's a high margin business.
That's good news, right? Because it
costs almost nothing to
produce. You have to maintain the
platform, but those are mostly fixed
costs. As you grow, your margins are
going to improve. So, you'll see margins
improving because of economies of
scale. Capital intensity is pretty low,
right? You got to invest in platforms
unless AI changes the game somehow, in
which case you have to think about what
that'll do. And finally, is it
discretionary,
nondiscretionary? I'm going to ask Leon,
how addicted do you use to Reddit,
right? I mean, that's really the
question. I mean, let's face it, social
med has an entire book on this and how
addictive social media platforms are.
Maybe there's an argument that social
media platforms have less risk than the
newspapers of yester year, making their
revenues less unstable. There's a story
here, right? So, Leon's going to work on
the story. Convert to numbers. Show me a
valuation and that valuation will be as
much a reflection of the story as it is
of the inputs that went in. Jessica, who
you
valuing? Don't worry, I'm sorry. My
mouth was full,
but Valente. Oh my god. I will let you
think about the story, right? Because
there are two branches to the story.
There's the defense part of the story.
There's the commercial part. It's
perhaps one of the toughest companies to
tell a story about because I've actually
even though I don't go on Reddit very
often, I sometimes have visited it. I
have never used a Palunteer
product. Jessica, have you? Okay. It's a
B more businessto business. You
encounter it more on a businessto
business basis. Already you can see
telling a story about a B2B company is
inherently more difficult than a BTOC
company.
and doesn't mean it's impossible. It's a
different story. So each of you, I want
you to already start thinking about the
story. So let's say you come up with a
story for your company. You say, "I'm
done. Not quite." Let's think about some
of the things that might change that
story. Okay? And you tell me whether any
of these could change the
story. Could a new earnings report from
your company change your story?
If it's Coca-Cola, it's unlikely, right?
What are you going to learn in a new
earnings report? But if it's Palanteer,
the next earnings report could be hugely
consequential because what could it
contain? It could contain the
announcement that the CIA has decided to
quadruple its investment in Palunteer
and spend more money on AI. That's going
to change the story. And already you can
see for young companies an earnings
report it's not the numbers it's what it
does to your
story. So an earnings report could a
macroeconomic change like inflation and
interest rates.
Yeah, at the margin at least, right? If
you're Walmart at today, you saw the
inflation numbers came out. They came in
a little less than expected. That's good
news. If you're a company where
inflation is the key driver of value,
less so of paler, right? That's it's a
side story. Could a regulatory
change affect your
story? At least for a subset of your
companies, right? If it's a heavy, if
it's a utility, if it's a telecom
company, changing regulations can make
you more. In fact, you could argue that
what happened to Google last week was a
regulatory shock. You know what I'm
talking about. Google was targeted by
the Justice Department last year and the
targeting was they were going to be
forced to sell off their browser, Google
Chrome and Androids. And then the
election happened and everybody assumed
the problem had gone away because it was
Lena Khan who was pushing for it and
last week the Justice Department
announced that it hadn't gone away that
they were going to continue with it.
What did Google stock price drop? It
dropped about 8
9%. Did it drop by too much? Well, the
only way to play it out is to look at
how this story plays out because this is
not the end of the story. This is the
start of a legal battle. It'll cost
money. It'll cost resources. And there
is a possibility, I think it's low, that
they will be forced to spin off or sell
off Google Chrome and
Android. Could an earning support from
another company affect the story for
your company? Julian, give me an
example.
Right. Amazon announces they're entering
the almost instantaneously. You know
what happened to Cheg when AI took off?
Czech is a homework company, right? So
basically they were growing fast. Then
AI comes along and it turns out that CH
GPT can answer the question explain the
hypotenuse theorem to me as well as a
person check value pretty much plummeted
towards
zero. All of the
above I mean people think of it as find
this unsettling. I find it fun. It's
interesting. This is why valuation is
interesting. You're never quite done.
This notion that you've told the right
story and it's timeless. You're not a
novelist. You're not written, you know,
to kill a mocking bird, right? This is a
story that's going to change because the
world is changing around you. And
welcome to the last two
weeks, right? Think of all all those
companies that two weeks ago you had a
story that now you got to revisit that
story with now I'm writing a piece on
Trump tariff and taxes that is very
little to say about Trump or tariff or
taxes but to talk about how we got to
where we
are because these are things that shake
your stories change your stories and
affect your value. One final point right
and I think we've kind of answered this.
Every valuation is a balance between
stories and numbers. But remember the
notion of a corporate life cycle that I
took you through. Young companies,
growing companies, mature companies,
declining companies. I want you to think
about that balance between stories and
numbers as you go through the life
cycle. So somebody during the lunch
break came in and they're valuing a
fintech company which kind of means
nothing, right? What kind of fintech?
This is the buy now pay later kind of
fintech. You know what that is? You go
buy a couch. You don't have money to buy
a couch. They will finance the buying of
the couch. It's a young fintech company
and the the group is trying to
value. When you think about valuing it,
there's no past data to go on. There's
really no basis for the projected
numbers. It's all about story. And
what's the story going to depend on? How
big is that market? What's that market
look like? Who's who's buying now?
Because you're not talking about buying
a house and paying later. You're talking
about buying a couch and paying later.
You're talking people who are about
people who are essentially at the very
edge of
economic. They're living paycheck to
paycheck. So what kind of default risk
will there be in there? Significant. So
the question you're asking is, is this a
company that charges a high enough
interest rate to cover their default
risk? And will there be shocks to this
company? In fact, what kind of macro
shock does this company have to worry
about? Recession. A recession, right?
because then you're not just going to
get three people defaulting and banks
have always faced this right. So how
have banks kind of buffered themselves
against
this? Even if they didn't do it, the
regulatory guys come in. So you need
regulatory capital. So the question
asked was do they
have a buffer? Because fintech companies
can many of them are regular play
regulatory arbitrage. What does that
mean? They're acting like banks. They're
lending to very risky people. They're
charging high interest rates. They're
going to look great for the
moment until that that that
that shock comes and then they're going
to go under and the scariest thing is
they basically will walk away. VCs would
have made money coming in at a low price
and a high price. It's I think an
opening in the fintech space that is
being exploited that you need to think
through. Young companies, it's mostly
stories. As companies age, the number is
kind of simp. The way I like to describe
this is when you're valing a young
company, it's like you've been called in
to finish a book that an author has
started. Not Daniel Steel because AI can
write that book, but somebody who's a
little more unpredictable. Right? So,
you're chapter one, the do the author's
died. You can't you now have 33 more
chapters. you can tell a very very
different story. In contrast with a
mature company, you're coming in in
chapter 18 of a 34 chapter book. The
characters have already been set. You
can't create skewed stories. And if
you're a declining company, you're in
chapter 33 of the 34 chapter book. Don't
create new characters who wander on. So
when you think about valuation, you can
already see as you move through the life
cycle, the tilt will be towards numbers.
And this is why pure number crunches got
away with it for so long because for
much of the last century and into this
one the typical company you valued in
public markets was a mostly mature
company. You're valing Coca-Cola and
craft times. You can be a pure Excel
ninja and get away with it because who
cares what the story is. So those are
all things I want to talk about. We'll
we'll we'll navigate those those those
those waters as we go through. But let
me first finish up something. The last
piece of the loose end puzzle. We talked
about the fact that more and more
companies pay their employees with
equity. That equity can take the form of
options. It can take the form of
restricted stock. And I already told you
up front restricted stock is the easier
problem to deal with because there are
two issues you got to deal with when you
have stockbased compensation. One is how
do you deal with the dead weight cost of
stockbased compensation that's been used
in the past. You know what I mean by
that? You've been giving options last
year, two years ago, three years ago,
four years ago. How do you deal with
that dead weight cost? The second is to
the extent that this company is going to
continue to use stockbased compensation,
how do you factor the debt to your
analysis? So let's start with the easier
problem restricted stock. What's
restricted stock? What part you know
when we say restricted stock? What's the
restriction on the stock? So if you get
restricted stock the time where when you
receive it so you that's vesting, right?
Vesting is one problem. Restricted sell
it for you can't sell it. So I think you
were going there as well. So there is a
restriction on trading. So already you
can see if I give you publicly traded
shares when I say you can't trade them
for the next two years there will be a
discount you will demand because you say
look I need
liquidity but restricted stock the
shares themselves are regular shares. So
when you have restricted shares the
solution is simple don't play games add
it to your regular shares. Having said
that though I find that most data
services are incredibly sloppy about
what they do with restricted stock.
Yahoo for instance finance when they
report the number of shares for a
company don't include restricted stock
which might not be a big deal if you're
looking at a big company like Apple but
looking at a company that's just going
public I remember valing Pelaton at the
time of their IPO there were like seven
classes of restricted stock because
they'd been you know paying employees
with restricted stock those shares need
to be counted in which requires that you
go through the footnotes it will not
show up in the balance sheet will not
show up in the in data services, you got
to kick through the
footnotes. I think one reason companies
have shifted to restricted stock is
options for a long time gave companies a
way of giving away stuff and not having
to reflect it. The accounting rules
changed in 2007. This might be pure
coincidence, but
pre207% of the compensation stockbased
compensation at US companies took the
form of options. Today 90% is a form of
restricted stock. Amazon hasn't issued
options forever. They have a few left
over from a decade ago. Companies have
moved to restricted stock. Thank God for
that. Easier to deal with in valuation.
Bring it in. If you expect this company
to continue to issue restricted stock in
the future, what will that mean? Well,
that's a drain on your income. And don't
give me that non-cash expense nonsense.
Restricted stock and options are not
non-cash expenses. They're inind
expenses. Essentially, you've taken a
slice of my equity. You've given it
away. That's a piece that's worth
something. All you did was skip a step,
right? If you taken the restricted
stock, issued it to the market, taken
the cash, and paid me, I'd have shown it
as an expense. I can't let you use a B
system to evade cash flows. So, past
restricted stock counted the share
count. Future restricted stocks show as
an expense lowering margins, earnings,
and cash flows in the future. Seems like
a double counting, but you're accounting
for two different things. Do you see
why? The past restricted stock, the
share count reflects it. Future
restricted stock, you basically reduce
your earnings cash flows and come up
with a lower
value. But let's talk about options. We
all know how options work, right? You
you know, typically employee options are
a little different from the options you
and I trade on the Chicago Board of
Options.
Jessica, they don't have to set aside a
portion of the balance sheet, right?
Because as a restricted shareholder,
you're like any other shareholder.
There's not there's nothing, you know,
with options, you have to come up with
shares to cover the option exercises. I
give you restricted stock. You actually
have shares in my company. The only
thing for the next two years, you can't
trade the shares, but you're like any
other shareholder in the company, right?
So it goes into it kind of disappears
into that that equity number that you
see on a balance sheet because you're
now an equity investor in the company
like everybody
else with options though. Yeah. Yes. Go
ahead. So when we reduce the um value of
the company because of the let's be
explicit the way we reduce it is by
giving them less earnings in the future
right we give them lower margins lower
cash flows lower value. Okay keep going.
So when we calculate value per share um
we will not of shares that that but that
number of shares will reflect past
restricted stock issues but you will not
count expected future restricted stock
issues. Why not? Because we already
accounted double counted right. So don't
mess with this future share count
change. It's a nightmare because you're
going to be in the circular logic
problem. Right? Because to figure out
how many shares you're going to have to
issue in the future, you got to figure
out what the price will be in the
future, right? Companies don't give
share count, they give value. So if your
my share is worth $1,000 per share,
invad $300 per share to give away fewer
restricted shares than $30 per share. So
that's why you want to avoid all future
share count issues and try to affect it
through the cash flows. You're going to
see me do the same thing with
options. Let's look at options, right?
So you're a shareholder in a company.
Let's say we're all shareholders in the
company. The company grants options.
Typically, when companies grant options
to employees, they're long-term. 10
years is a typical term for an option.
That already makes it a little unusual.
Long-term options. Typically, when
companies grant options, they give them
at the money. You know what I mean by at
the money? The stock price is 10. The
You're saying that's worthless. No, you
got 10 years to play with this game,
right? An at the money option is
definitely not worthless. And this is
where accountants made their fatal
mistake between before 2007. If you as a
company, you know, granted options, if
they were at the money, accountants said
they were worth
nothing. One of the most nonsensical
perspectives because it led to some
really, really bad behavior. Right? If
if you're a company and I tell you
options at the money are worth nothing,
a thousand times nothing is worth
nothing. Million times nothing is worth
nothing. 10 million times nothing is
worth nothing. So what do you do? You
give away large slices. It doesn't
affect your earnings. It doesn't show up
in your share count and your accountant
says don't
worry. 3 years later the stock is up
50%. And all of a sudden you wake up to
the fact that you've given away 20% of
the company. So when you look at
options, the reason they become an issue
is even though they're granted at the
money, if the stock price goes up,
employees can now buy the shares
effectively at a discount and you and I
will bear that discount. Again, I'm not
I can understand why companies give
options, but don't lie to my face and
tell me they're worth nothing because
they are worth
something. You see, what if stock prices
go down? Stock prices go down. What do
employees do?
they don't exercise. It's a one-sided
game, right? You get the downside, you
get no upside. So options have always
have value even if they're at or below
the stock
price. So with that in place, I'm going
to set up a very simple example to
illustrate the three ways in which I see
analysts deal with options. One is
extraordinarily lazy, but unfortunately
a lot of analysts take this back. The
second looks okay because it looks like
you but there are implicit assumptions
here that should worry you. And the
third is the one that I'm going to push
you towards because I think it's the
right way to deal with options. So I'm
going to present you with a company.
Company has 100 million in free cash
flows growing 3% a year in perpetuity
with an 8% cost of
capital. If you think about those
numbers basically you put in 100 million
is expected free cash flow divided by
0.08 08 minus 003. The value of the firm
is 2 billion. It's got a billion dollars
in debt. You subtract that out, you get
a billion in equity. And let's say that
in this company, there are 100 million
shares outstanding. The value per share
is
$10. It's a pretty trivial example,
right? Let's say you value the company
shares at $10. And this company now
grants 10 million options to its
CEO with a strike price of $10. So
what's the accountant going to tell you?
Don't worry, they're at the money. But I
want to ask you a question about what
your value per share would remember it
was $10 before this grand. And I'll give
you the three choices. First is you
listen to the accountants and say
they're at the money so it doesn't
affect me, right? The second is that the
value should decrease by roughly 10%
because you have 10% more shares now
than you did before. So it's a very
conservative way of saying the options
have been granted. I'm going to count
the
shares. The third is it'll decrease but
not by 10%. That there's something that
buffers that impact because at 10% you
just count the number of shares. You're
not counting in the exercise price and
everything coming in. So here are the
three ways in which people deal with
options. The first is they take the
billion dollars in value of equity that
we got before, but instead of dividing
by the 100 million shares outstanding,
they divide by 110 million. It's called
fully diluted. Basically, use the fully
diluted
count. You come up with a value of $99,
but I can almost guarantee you've
undervalued the company. Why is that?
What what are they missing with when
they do the 10 million additional
shares? First, they're assuming the
options will be exercised, right? What
else are they assu they're missing?
When those options get exercised, what
do the employees have to do? They've got
to pay $10, right? That's a that's a mis
How do you miss that? You've assumed
their exercise. Okay, I'll go along with
you. But where did the $10 per share
go? So, the second approach fixes that.
It's an easy fix. What do you do? You
take the $10 per share that you're
getting from the option exercise times
10 million. You come up with a 100
million as the additional cash. So, you
play it out. It's going to get exercised
right away. That's a 100 million in
cash. That increases my numerator. I
divide by 110 and the value per share I
get seems to agree with what the
accountants told me.
Right? This is called the treasury stock
approach. Analysts all over the world
use it. But when you use it, what are
you implicitly assuming? There is no
time value on the option.
So the
$99 you're undervaluing the company. The
$10 you're overvaluing the company.
There must be a Goldilock solution. And
here's the Goldilock solution. You take
the 10 million options, you value them
as options. So here's the process. You
start by doing what you traditionally
do. Don't even think about options while
you're doing the valuation of your
company. Don't let it distract you.
Value the firm. Subtract our debt so
far. Add cash, subtract that. You come
up with the value of equity. But before
you divide by the number of shares, I
want you to pause and value those 10
million options as options. You say,
"What the heck does that even mean?"
What do option pricing models do? Forget
about the the specifics of the model.
When you black shows a binomial to value
an option, what exactly does that value
reflect? What do you want to
try? You come up with a value, right?
You plug these numbers SN D1 K E minus
RT. You say what's this foreign
language? But at the end there's a
number at the end. But if I ask you to
intuit intuitively describe what that
number is, what is it trying to
measure? First, there's a normal
distribution, right? What is that doing?
It's capturing the fact that stock
prices can go up or down. It's capturing
the fact that if there's more movement
in there, there is an expected
likelihood that your option will get
exercised. It's trying to compute an
expected value for your options across
all scenarios. That's basically what the
option pricing model is. If you strip it
of all of its all its mistake, it's a
way of capturing the expected value of
these options given how uncertain your
stock is. In fact, to see why that is
so, if you make the normal distribution
into have a standard deviation of zero,
fact it's certain, what happens to the
value of your
option? It goes to zero. So in that
special case where there's no
uncertainty, the value of the option
goes away. So as I increase the
uncertainty, the expected value of the
option goes up. We've had option pricing
models now for 50 years, but when
employee options came along, they were
troublesome. They were tough to fit into
option pricing models. And here's why.
The Black Scholes model, the original
option pricing model is designed to
value options on the Chicago Board of
Options. If you get a chance, check out
that page, the Chicago Board of Options
page. You're not going to get 10ear
options. You're getting three-month
options. So, it was designed to value
short-term options. That's the first
problem. The second is if you exercise
an option on the Chicago Board of
Options, it's a it's a side game between
two players. It's got nothing to do with
the company.
When you exercise a management
option, the share count can actually
change. Do you see why? Because a
company issues shares, the share count
can change. So here there's actually an
effect on the price, but the act of
exercising an option will change the
price per
share. This is a circularity because you
go to exercise the option thinking it's
in the money. The very act of announcing
that you're exercising can lower the
stock price. The third is the black
trolls model was designed to value what
were called
European
options. It's a very, you know,
unfortunate choice of phrase because it
suggests it's got something to do with
geography. It doesn't. Right,
Constantine? What's a European
option? You can pass it to France. He
knows he's ready to give the answer. And
European one I I I know that there are
two types of option European and
American I said
is exercisable until the maturity date
and the other is the other way around.
So exercised on after the the musion no
none of them can be exercised after one
can be exercised only on the maturity
day that's European option the other can
be exercised any time of so if I gave
you a choice between a European American
option every other character is the same
which one should be valued a little more
highly the American because you get all
of the rights of the European plus black
should designed to value European
options we use it all the time to value
American options you know why we get
away with talked about the Chicago Board
of
Options. 98% of the options, maybe 96%
of the options, the Chicago Board of
Options get exercised in the last minute
of the last
day. And there's a reason why, right?
Let's say you buy a call option on Tesla
because you think it's coming back.
Stock price right now is 220. It's down
50%, said this is it. This is the
bottom. Let's say in a week the stock
goes to
300. You guessed right. Right. You
bought a call option. There are two
things you can do. One is exercise and
collect the difference between 300 and
the exercise price. What the other thing
you can
do? You can sell the option. And you see
why selling is going to beat exercising
almost every single time. Because when
you sell, you'll get whatever you got
from exercise plus a time
premium. with regular listed options
because they're traded. You almost never
get early
exercise. But let's say you're an
employed Nvidia and you got options in
2018. You know the adjusted stock price
was then because there's a 10 for one
stock was $2.80 per
share. So you have a million options you
got at $2.80 per share. What are those?
What's the stock price now? Even after
the drop in the last couple of weeks,
$110 per
share, you're a rich person. At least on
paper,
right? You're worth $110
million. You have 6 years left in the
option. Do you see now in this case why
you might be torn between exercising
early and waiting? You can't sell those
options. Management options are not
sellable. They're not liquid. So you
could say I'm going to fall for the time
premium. But what could happen in the
next six years? Nvidia could go back to
30 or 40. So with management options,
you are going to get early exercised. In
fact, it's estimated that management
options get exercised about half
employee options get exercised about
halfway to their maturity date cuz
people just get scared. And I can't
blame them. This is completely rational.
You want to cash out saying if I wait it
might wipe out my 100 million it might
go back to 2 million or
zero. So already you can see option
pricing models have all these mechanical
challenges and for a long time that's
the excuse accountants use for we can't
value options because option pricing
models don't work with employee options.
That's not true though. You can adapt
option pricing models to value it by
factoring in a dilution effect. I'll
show you how I do it. And by reducing
the maturity if you need to, right?
Instead of a 10-year maturity, use a
5year
maturity. And that's basically what I
did. I took that 10 million share 10
million options granted. The strike
price is $10. Technically, it looks like
it's at the money, but the minute you
exercise, I can compute the dilution
effect. It's actually fairly
straightforward. The stock will drop to
958. So, basically, I'm going to use
that diluted stock price of 958. It's a
slightly out of the money
option. I'm going to leave the maturity
at 10 years. I could have brought it
down to five if I wanted. I valued the
option at
$542 per
option. What does that capture? It
captures the expected value of this at
the money option if you let it ride for
the next 10 years. They gave away 10
million options. That's worth 54.2
million. So, I take the billion dollars
in equity. I subtract out the 54.2 2
million saying I've given it away.
That's an equity slice I've given away.
I come up with
945.8 million as the remaining equity
and that I divide by the 100 million
shares. Don't divide by 110 because
that'll be double counted. But the way
to deal with options is to value them as
options. Take them out of your equity
because you created the second equity
claim on your company. So when you look
at employee options, much as accountants
say it can't be done, since 2007, this
is what companies have had to
do. So option pricing models have
actually become pretty good at value. So
now when you look at a Cisco and you
look at their cost of goods sold, it
does include employee options already.
The right thing to do, right? But to
show you no good deed ever goes
unpunished, what do companies and
analysts repeatedly do on every company
after they get the earnings from
accountants? They add back the
stockbased compensation creating
concoctions like adjusted EBA adjusted
for what added all the stockbased. What
is wrong with you
guys? Why would you add it back? It's
not as if it's like depreciation. It's a
nice cash flow. This is an actual
expense. You gave away pieces of my
equity. There is zero excuse for doing
what companies and analysts are doing.
But you know why they do it? Because
anal No, I would love to say it's taxes.
That's actually rational. It doesn't
change your taxes 1 cent. Because your
taxes said by the tax guy, the fact that
you add it back doesn't make the tax go
away. It's because so many analysts, how
do they put a price on a company? What's
every analyst's favorite multiple now?
It used to be P ratio 40 years ago.
Today it's EV to EBIDA. It's every
banker's magic. You know, EV to Eida,
EIDA multip. So, what the heck are you
doing? EIDA multiple as if you know. And
they're arguing it's a cash flow. It's a
very rough measure of cash. It's a
halfast cash flow because you added back
the depreciation. You want to do cash
flows. What about capex? No, no. I'm
just stopping after
DA. So if I know you're a lazy analyst
who prices companies at eight times
EBA and I'm a company, you send an
invitation to me, right? You want me to
pump up EBA. I'll find ways to do it.
And that's exactly what the adjuster if
you don't believe. Take take one of
these IPOs. There'll be an adjust it's
for for laughs alone going looking at
what they add back.
Airbnb came up with this version of
adjusted EBIDA that or we work came up
with a version of adjusted EBIDA where
they basically took the expenses
associated with running the buildings
which is an operating expense and add
back and called it some
community expense. I what it's a
community adjusted EITA I said now we're
talking right what the heck does that
even mean? It'll be like Uber saying I'm
going to add back the 80% that we pay
for drivers and call it a driver
adjusted
EIDA. But we reap what we sow. If we
take eight times EBIT die and we're not
careful, that's exactly the game you're
going to play. So when you look at
options, don't play that game. And if
you have options in the future, they
become part of expenses. They reduce
your earnings. Usually what happens is
companies scale up is option expenses
drop off as a percent of revenues. You
know why? Cuz eventually they get
replaced with cash re cash expenses. You
start to pay your employees with cash. I
know I don't know whether Amazon was the
large largest hireer out of Stern, but a
couple of years ago, three years ago,
Amazon was one of the largest hirers out
of Stern for MBAs, you know, and wager
that their paycheck is mostly cash now.
Unlike, you know, 10, 20 years ago where
it would be mostly options, that tends
to happen in companies. The total
compensation is not changing but less
and less of it comes from
equity. Any questions on equity
compensation as I said don't even play
the adjusted earnings game. No. So when
an analyst says I've added back
stockbased compensation this there are
very few things I would say you should
draw a line on this is
malpractice. There's no justification
for doing it. I don't care what an
analyst has been doing and he's doing
doing it for 30 years. It still just
doesn't make sense.
Yes. The end of the day, it is a
non-cash expense. It's not a non-cash
expense. Let's not Let's suppose I used
options to pay all my
suppliers. Let's say I used options to
pay all of my cost of goods sold. It's
my revenue my cash flow. Because with
your logic, then if it's not actual
cash, you're not going to treat it as a
cash flow. It is an inind expense.
Here's what I mean by you skipped a
step. You took those options. You should
them to market. Can companies do that?
They're called words. You'd have got
cash, right? Let's say you took that
cash and paid employees. Would have been
a cash expense. All I did was barter. If
you let me use a barter system to evade
cash flows, I'm going to use bers to
make my revenues into free cash flow and
ask you to give me a really high value
for my company. And that makes zero
sense. The best way to actually do this
to illustrate to somebody who really is
stuck on this is take two companies with
exactly the same numbers but with one
add an extra million dollars in
stockbased compensation. If they're
using their measures of free cash, they
both will have the same free cash flow.
Ask them how much they would pay per
share for the two companies. They say
the same. Sell them the shares in the
company with the option because they
clearly have no idea what they're doing
because they're paying for something
that's not there. So don't let that
non-cash excuse come out. Make it an
issue of inind versus non-cash.
Depreciation is a non-cash expense.
Stock-based compensation is not a
non-cash expense. It's an inkind expense
where you given away slice. In fact, the
analogy I would use and I might have
used it here is we own a pizzeria. Have
we used this example? No. and I have
five employees and I pay them minimum
wages because that's all I can afford to
pay and they're all threatening to leave
because there's a restaurant down the
street which will pay them $2 more. I
cut a deal with them. At the end of
every day, I give them three
pizzas to take home in addition to the
pay. It's non-cash expense, right? Or is
it? I could have sold the three pizzas
and made the money. I've given away the
pizzas.
I am less valuable as a company if I
have to give out 15 full pizzas every
day. That's exactly the way to think
about employee options. You're giving
away pieces of my business and I've got
to value it. I'm not saying you
shouldn't use stockbased compensation,
but I'm saying I'm going to make sure
that I capture it in my value
position. So now let's talk
about stories and numbers. We started
the class with this debate about know
which are you you know where would you
put yourself? Are you more naturally a
storyteller or you more naturally a
number
cruncher? I'm going to ask you I think
at that point in you know kind of make
that judgment for yourself. Let's have a
show of hands again. How many of you are
more naturally number
crunchers? All the tech MBAs except for
Julian.
Yeah. And don't I mean there's nothing
wrong with this. How many and know let
me ask a question Jessica. When did you
know that number crunching was what you
liked to do
more? Not not when you were in six,
second grade or third. I mean, remember
this starts very early, right? Cuz you
have a math class followed by social
studies and you say, "Ah, I hate that
class." You know, you'll have to learn
the history of the colonial war. Who the
hell cares?
you're already starting your number
crunching journey right in junior I mean
my wife teaches fifth grade if one of my
her fifth graders came and say I don't
want to come into the social studies
class she's going to say you've got to
sit in it's not a choice but as you get
older you get to make
choices you get to high school and you
pick your AP classes not picking AP
history if you're a number cruncher
you're picking AP math AP
chemistry then you get out of high
school, then you go on to college. Now,
of course, you got that core curriculum
crap in the middle here where they make
you take all the classes you don't
really
need. But then you get past that, you
pick the classes through, you get a
number crunching degree. It could be
engineering, it could be actuarial
science, it could be software, you know,
whatever it is. And then you go to work
in a number crunching job. And who do
you hang out with? Other numberc
crunching people, right?
and you share the same
delusions. The delusion of
precision. It's a delusion, but you
know, you add three extra decimal
points. The delusion that you're not
that you're being objective because you
use numbers. And the delusion that
you're in
control. You know what I mean by the
delusion you're in control? You measure
risk. You know why? Because you think by
measuring risk, somehow you control
risk. It's delusions because none of
those are true.
I want to pick on some of the
storytellers. Not Julian because he did
go to a not a typical storytelling
place. He went to work for
Airbnb though they do tell a lot of
stories sometimes. Right. Right. So what
did you do at Airbnb
Julian? This is not a number crunching
destination usually. Right. It's usually
you know this is usually a number it's
not a storytelling destination. Did your
parents force you to do this or
something? I mean, if you're Indian, I
would have assumed that's what happened,
right? Because in Indian, you're a
storyteller. You go to your parents and
say, "I want to get a history major."
They're going to slap you around the
face saying, "Go become an engineer."
Right? So, I'm assuming that that did
not happen to you. So, somewhere you
took a pathway and ended up in a what
would typically be called a number
crunching job? Any typical storytelling
job people
here? You think what's a storytelling
job? I mean
Dagmar marketing very much storytelling
strategy lot of storytelling journalism
storytelling run
rampant there are storytelling
jobs different skill sets and if you go
into storytelling you hang out with a
lot of marketing people right you tell a
lot of big stories around lunch nobody's
putting any discipline in these stories
you talk about the three Ps or the four
Ds or whatever it is in marketing
And essentially you hang out with and
you have your own set of delusions like
what you tell if you tell a big story I
should give you a high
value. You also have a lot of
anecdotal examples come up. Why should
we do it? Because Coca-Cola did it in
2003. Let's face it. Harvard invented
case studies as essentially anecdotal
evidence for you to do whatever you
wanted. some companies some time point
in time did this and it worked therefore
you should do it if you think about case
studies statistically it's an awful way
to learn business because using one
example set in time to do
this so I think and that divide is
getting worse and worse 40 years ago you
could have become an investment banker
as a history major if you had the right
connections and you could tell a good
story today the tribes are getting
separate
In fact, in the investing business, you
talk to a bunch of VCs, you know what
you're going to hear? Lots of stories.
VCs are terrible with
numbers. You move and talk about the
same company to eight bankers, Ebida
multiples over and over again. You know,
it's and I think that we're losing a
connection to valuation because of that.
So, good valuation is a bridge between
stories and numbers. So what I'd like to
do is take you through the process by
which I tried to do valuation because
and I follow this process because if I
don't follow the process, I know exactly
how this will end. I'm going to start
trying to value a company very quickly
open an Excel spreadsheet and go off to
the races. So I've got to slow the
process down to let my weak side play
out. So when I look at a company and
don't care what the company is, my first
step is to tell a story about the
company. What does that require?
requires me to understand what the
company does. If I don't know what the
company does, there's no way I can value
the company. What does it make? Who buys
it? Why do they like it? What does the
market look like? What does the
competition look like? Some of this is
data, right? And a lot of it is just
talking to people. If you've never used
a company's product, I remember when
Beyond Meat filed for for its public
offering, the first thing I did was
drive to the grocery store and buy two
packs of Beyond Meat. Why? What's Beyond
Meat's claim to fame?
This Pabased protein that tastes What's
your first reaction? There's a Pabased
protein that tastes exactly like steak.
You're right. Your answer is right. And
that was my reaction and said, "But
there must be something there." So I
drove to the grocery store. I bought two
packs. I brought it home. I think one
was this Beyond Meat ground meat version
and another was a Beyond Meat, you know,
whatever chicken
chunks. And they they did taste a lot
like meat. So I said, "Okay." Then I
keep reading the IPO and they talk about
this potentially huge market. I'm
saying,
"Where?" I mean the market I think of is
guiltridden meat
eaters in the US or Europe who love meat
but feel that the cl the world is going
to hell in a hand basket and they need
to do something. But you know what they
were talking about is a huge market.
They were talking about all these
vegetarians in the world who will now be
able to eat things that taste exactly
like meat. And my reaction was this
story has a hole in it the size of the
Titanic. I grew up in a part of India
where I was surrounded by vegetarians
who had never eaten meat. If you gave
them something that tastes exactly like
meat, they are going to freak out.
They're going to say, "What disgusting
thing have you put in front of me?" And
this is why we need to test stories
because there's probably some guy
sitting in the Beyond Meat office say
there are 300 million vegetarian
Indians. What a big market out there
waiting for us. It's not waiting for you
now or
ever because you've never ever
encountered what these people eat. And
this is not something that's not in the
top 1,000. They could be dying of hunger
in a desert island and you can go to
them with Beyond Meat and they say, "I'd
rather
die." First step in valuation is
understanding what a company does. So,
I'm going to take a company as my lab
experiment to illustrate this. It was
June of
2014 and I was reading the Wall Street
Journal, the physical version. I no
longer do it. I have a digital version,
the physical version. And I see a news
story about a company called Uber and I
make a confession. June of 2014, I'd
never heard of
Uber. You say, "What? Did you live
underground?" Technically,
yes. Cuz I lived most of the time in New
York and I always took the subway. I
never took car
service. I shouldn't say I never heard
of Uber. I'd seen the word Uber on my
credit card statements in the months
leading into June of 2014. Turned out
that my second son was going to college
in North
Carolina, was using Uber and using my
credit card. I don't know how that
happened but I thought he was taking
German language right the nolad on the
you should have kind of given it away so
I read the story that says that Uber had
raised $3 billion from venture
capitalist would price the company at 17
billion I'm using the words deliberately
priced the company at 17 billion
surprised a German language class worth
17 billion so I decide to guess who I
call
first I call my
But it was 11:30 in the morning and he
was still
sleeping. He kept college student hours.
You know what those are? There's nothing
to do with the sun coming up and the sun
going down. It's some celestial
variation of that. They have no time
zone. So basically there's no such thing
as being in the wrong time zone. My
youngest son still does this. He comes
to California and he sleeps in from New
York, right? He sleeps until 2:00 in the
afternoon. No, but 11:30 in the morning,
he wasn't picking up his
phone. Must have been on silent mode.
So, I called my niece who lived and
worked in Chicago. And she had she was
technically awake cuz she had a job and
she was sitting at her desk, but she was
in an awful mood. She picks up the
phone. She says, "What do you want?"
This is how she greets her favorite
uncle. I said, "Have you heard of this
company called Uber?" She said, "It's a
ride sharing company." I said, "What the
heck is a ride sharing company?" She
said, "I don't have the time to tell
you. Why don't you download the app and
find out for yourself?" Hangs up the
phone. Add manners, right? But I'm
sitting up in my office in the ninth
floor. I download the app. I hit the
app and a magical things start to happen
on my phone. The GPS opens up and I see
a car trying to drive towards 44 West
Fourth Street. Why try? In New York
City, you don't get from point A to
point B. You try. Go in the general
direction. You zigg and you zag. So I
can see the car zigging and zagging and
I can see the name of the driver,
George. I'm fascinated. Never happened
to me with a yellow
cap. 15 minutes later, the guy pulls up
in front. At that time, we didn't have
all these fencing in front, so I just
ran out there and said, "Hi, George." He
said, "You didn't enter a destination.
Where do you want to go?" I said,
"Nowhere in particular, but you drive me
around for about 30 minutes. I have some
questions to ask you." He thought for a
brief moment I was a serial
killer, but he must have decided, I can
take this guy. He said, 'Get in the
back, ask me the question. So I said,
"Is this an Uber car you're driving?" He
said, "No, this is my car." I said, "Why
are we doing this?" He said, "I have a
job. I don't get paid much. This allows
me to earn a second income, the car." I
said, "Why do you need Uber?" He said,
"In New York City, it's illegal to stop
on the streets and offer somebody a
ride." And that's actually technically
true. You can't be a gypsy cab and just
stop on the street. He said Uber
connects me with
customers. So I kind of got why this guy
was doing what he was doing. Took a car
he already own. I did ask him, "Did you
tell your insurance company you're doing
this on the side?" He said, "What they
don't know can't hurt them." I said,
"Okay." Right? So he drops me off 30
minutes later. I offer to pay him. He
said, "You don't have to pay me." I
said, "It's free." He said, "It's not
free." Said, "Did you enter a credit
card when you downloaded the app?" I
said, "Yes." He said, "They will charge
you." I said, "How do you get paid?"
Shows you how completely unaware I was
with this business. He said, "They pay
me, they send me 80% of the fair." I
said, "Why 80%. Why not 85 70?" He said,
"I don't know. That's what they all do."
And he drives off. So, at this point, I
knew why Uber did what they did for
connecting cars to customers, neither of
which they got a 20% share. Nice
business to be in. Which left me with
one final actually two final questions.
The first was why do people like my son
and my niece like Uber? To give you some
perspective, this particular son of mine
is incapable of hailing a yellow cab. I
can't even imagine him. Imagine him
doing that now because how do you h
yellow cab in New York City? What do you
have to do? You've got to go out in the
street, put your hand up there, wave,
and the cab has not for higher, not for
higher. It kind of flips and not flips.
Maybe you stop, maybe you won't. See,
no, it's probably the same technology
that was used in the late 1800s to hail
a horse
carriage. This this kid of mine is
incapable of doing this. So, I was
curious, why would he take a car? So, I
said, you know, I called him this time
and he had no excuse for sleeping. 3:30
in the afternoon, the basketball game
was on and I knew you'd be awake. I
said, "I noticed you've been using my
credit card to back up your ride
sharing." Acted like I knew what it was
right in the beginning. He said, "Why
would you want to do that? You took a
car down with you to North Carolina when
you went for college. Why would you need
to use Uber?" He said,
"Dad, on Friday
nights and Saturday nights, I really
like Uber."
Now, as a parent, there are some
followup questions you don't ask. What
exactly is special about Friday nights
and Saturday nights? But I kind of got
it. I said, "What do you like about
Uber?" He said, "I can call the car from
the bar." He say,
"Okay, but you must wait forever,
right?" He said, "No, they come sooner
than a cab." He said, "It must cost a
lot, right?" He said, "They're cheaper
than a cab. The cars must be filthy,
right?" No, they're cleaner than a cab.
I said, "Let me get this straight. They
come sooner than a cab. They're cheaper
than a cab. They're cleaner than a
cab. Cab service is destined for doom
for lots of different reasons. So now I
could see why right sharing companies
would take off. This is very early in
the
game. And then there was one final
question. What's so special about Uber?
It's an intermediary. Why couldn't I get
a really powerful computer, install it
in my basement, connect cars to
customers, take 20%. And there are two
things that Uber had that I did not. One
was $3 billion. They did, I didn't. So,
it's a bit of a problem. The second is
this is a business with what I call
networking
benefits. What does that mean? If you're
a ride sharing company, as you grow, it
actually gets easier to grow. Why?
Because if you're a driver, you want to
go where everybody else is. So, it's a
it's almost, you know, it's essentially
a business with where as you succeed,
you're basically going to push out the
competition. The endgame in this
business is you're going to get one
maybe two players in any particular area
because it's a business where that's
what you're going to end up
in. That was my research on Uber. You're
saying why don't you look at their
financials? What
financials? The company was privately
owned, extraordinarily secretive, and
the only two numbers I knew about Uber
was how much they collected as gross cab
fair, the total fair the previous year,
which they had leaked to one venture
capitalist, and how much money they lost
in the previous year, which they had
leaked to a different venture
capitalist. Two
numbers. But let's face it, even if I
had access to all of the financials for
Uber, what would I have
learned? they they don't make much in
revenues. They lose a lot of money. I
knew that already. So, one of the things
to recognize with young companies is the
absence of financials might seem like a
huge issue, but it's not going to help
you if I gave you every financial in the
company because there's not much
there. So, I actually drew a picture and
I try to do this every time I try when I
sit down to value company to understand
what drives the company. I drive you
know. So, it basically is a picture of
what I just described. How does Uber
make money? Why do customers like Uber?
Why do drivers drive for
Uber? What makes Uber different from
competitors in the
business? So that was my starting point,
my research, understanding the business.
Second stop, I want to tell a
story about the company. And I want to
remind you, you're not a creative
novelist. You're telling a business
story. I have two pieces of advice.
First, keep it simple.
I'll tell you the type of story you
should not tell as a business story. But
15 years ago, my oldest son came to me
with a reading suggestion. He said,
"Dad, you got to read this amazing
book." Gives me this book. It's 1,200
pages thick. I turn the book and look at
the title. It says Game of
Thrones, George RR. There are two Rs in
the middle. That kind of puzzled me. Why
are there two Rs in the middle? You
know, I tried.
I take my kids suggestions very
seriously. Halfway through the book, I
called him and said, "Ryan, I'm too old
for this." They're like hundreds of
characters in this book. They wander on,
they wander off, they die, they come
back to life. They're bad guys, they're
good guys. I kind of give up on this. I
prefer to stick with the Disney version.
There's a good guy, there's a bad guy.
Nothing in the
middle. If you're telling a business
story, don't make it Game of Thrones.
You don't have eight seasons and 80
episodes to tell your story. You have
like 15 minutes. Keep it simple and keep
it focused. What's the end game for any
business? You got to show me a pathway
to make money. I know you can't make
money now, but tell me at least you've
thought about that
possibility because we haven't thought
about it. It's not magically going to
show up on its own. You know how many
people or founders
or want to want to be founders? I listen
to their stories and they're usually
tech people who are very fascinated with
their own technology. They spend about
25 minutes telling you how amazing their
product is, how great their platform is,
how many people use the platform, and
then I stop and say, "That's all great,
but how do you plan to make money?" You
say, "What? I'm supposed to make money?"
Yeah. Having millions of people visit
your platform does absolutely nothing
for me. The reaction is I'll think about
it later.
When you're designing a business, you
got to think about it right from the
beginning. Is it a subscriptionbased
business? You're going to build your
platform very differently than if it's a
transaction-based business or an
advertising based business. Keep it
simple. Keep it focused. So, I'm going
to take my own advice and tell you my
Uber story in June of 2014. The reason I
keep emphasizing that date is I valued
Uber pretty much every year since 2014.
Do you think my story
changed? The core story might be a car
service, but the if you look at the car
service business, think of all the
things regulatory, legal, California
Supreme Court of 2016 said drivers are
employees. You can't do this independent
contractor crap. Think of all the things
that happen. Each of those things in a
sense alter your story and your value.
I'll show you a later valuation of Uber,
but this is the June 2014 version. And
in June of 2014, here was my story for
Uber. I described them as an urban car
service
business. Every word here is going to
have consequences. So when I describe
Uber as an urban car service business,
I'm describing them as succeeding in
cities and big
towns as a car service
business. Second, which will bring in
new users into this business. people
like my son who would not have been part
of the car service business are going to
come in because they feel more
comfortable with the
technology. Third, I did assume that
this is a business with local networking
benefits. You see, what does that mean?
I talked about networking benefits where
if Uber becomes the largest ride sharing
company in New York City, there'd be a
tipping point where effectively they
dominate the
city. You're saying what's a local doing
there? In my story, Uber can take New
York, Lyft can take Chicago, DD can take
Beijing, Grab can take Koala Lumpur and
Ola can take Mumbai. What does that
mean? The total car service market
around the world is not going to have
two or three players. It's going to have
eight or 10 or 15 players. The market
share that I get. And finally, in 2014,
I did assume they could keep doing what
they were doing. Remember that 20% was
absolutely arbitrary.
I'm convinced that Travis Galatnik had
dinner the previous night had tipped 20%
on his dinner and he was thinking about
hey what should I take of this slice he
said 20% sounds
good and finally I did assume they could
continue to not own the cars and not
hire the
drivers that's a story I'm going to
build on but before I build on that
story I've got to stop and make sure
that I haven't fooled myself remember in
valuation the person you got to worry
about fool fooling the most is yourself.
You can delude yourself if you really
really like a company. So, I pass it
through what I call the 3P test. Is it
possible? Is it plausible? Is it
probable? Sounds like I'm playing on
words. Each one I'm upping the antic.
Possible means it can be done. It's a
very low threshold. Plausible means
somebody somewhere has done something
like this, maybe in a different
business. Probable means you can show me
some evidence that you've tried this out
in a part of the world and your story is
actually held up.
I've struggled with ways of explaining
the difference between the three and um
a few years ago I was in Latin America
about 10 years ago right after I wrote
the narrative in numbers book and I was
giving the session in three Latin
American cities first day I was in Sa
Paulo Brazil second day in Santiago
Chile and third day in Lima Peru and I'm
doing the session on possible plausible
problem first day I lined up before 300
Brazilians in Sa Paulo and say I want to
pick a topic where Every person in this
room is going to have an opinion.
So help me out here. What's the topic I
would pick? Okay. So, okay. 6 months
before the that 2018 World Cup and ask a
question. Is it
possible that Brazil will win the World
Cup? You ask 300 Brazilians 6 months
before a World Cup. Is it possible now
Brazil win the World Cup? What's your
answer you get? Of course. Then I said,
"Is it plausible that Brazil will never
come?" If id asked this question in
November or December of 2014, the room
would have been shaky. I won't ask you
why because it's a painful wound you
want to cover over. But there was a
World Cup in 2014 that happened to be in
Brazil where Brazil got to the
semi-finals. Here's where the good story
ends. They played Germany in one of the
great shellacings of all
time. So luckily, this was three years
later. They the amnesia had developed.
They forgot all about 2014. They were
second ranked in the world. They said,
"Yeah, it's plausible." Then I said, "Is
it probable that Brazil won the World
Cup?" And now you can see the wheel
start to go into motion. We're in the
right group and Neymar stays healthy and
this happens and this
happens. It works so well in
Brazil. I decided to take to Santiago,
Chile. And I did not do my homework. So
I get in front of a 100 Chileans and I
say, "Is it possible that Chile will win
the World Cup?" Grown men in the
audience start weeping
uncontrollably. You know what had
happened the week before Chile had lost
to Argentina, been knocked out of World
Cup contention. I think one of the
things you need to do to win a World Cup
is actually be
there. Is it possible? No. the rest
becomes I feel pretty much in the same
place as a Yankee fan today. Any any
fellow Yankee fans here? It's been a
tough
week. A week ago, if you ask me could
the Yankees win. Four weeks ago, if you
ask me four, could they win? Possible,
plausible, even probable. Just two
pieces away. That feels like a distant
past now because in the last four weeks
we've lost Gian Carlos Stanton and two
days ago we lost Jared Cole. So you have
no idea who I'm talking about. Those two
big pieces possible, plausible, probable
already. You can see I can do possible.
Why? Because every team is at zero wins
and zero losses right now. But the
plausible has become tougher and
probable has become much slower.
That's the kind of So, I have a an
assignment for you after class today.
Sometime this evening, I want you to
find an old Shark
Tank episode. Right now, it's all
recorded. You can watch it. You can stop
it. So, you know the standard format,
right? A founder gets up and describes
the business they're starting. I want
you to think about three questions you
would ask that
founder before the sharks jump in. And
the questions have to try to eek out is
this business possible? Is it plausible?
Is it probable? Right. I've heard
founders on that describe business
completely
impossible. But if we pass the possible,
you're saying can we pull it off? I'm
looking for evidence. Did you try this
in the city? Who bought it? So if you're
a yoga instructor, you've done really
well and you talk about starting 500
yoga centers. Well, the question is how
do you replicate yourself if you are
center? So I'm trying to figure out how
much of you has made this center
successful, possible, plausible,
probable because we are
surrounded by stories that are
impossible, implausible, and improbable.
Let me give an example of an impossible
story. You know what a fairness opinion
is? What is a fairness opinion?
It's basically a fig leaf that an
acquiring company
gets to protect themselves, give them
legal protection against getting sued
when they overpay on an acquisition,
which is more common than actually
paying a decent price. The Delaware
courts in 1986 created this rule that if
you do an acquisition and you get a
fairness opinion, even if you overpay,
it could be the worst deal in the world
that your shareholders couldn't sue you
because a banker signed off saying this
value is
fair. Which raises an interesting
question. Has there ever been a deal
that has not gone through because you
could not get a fairness opinion? The
answer is absolutely not. What does it
tell you? Fairness opinions are where
valuation first principles go to die
because bankers essentially have to
do defend the indefensible come up with
numbers. So they break every single rule
in valuation. This is about 10 years
ago. One of the most hopelessly
conflicted deals of all time when Tesla
acquired Solar City. To see why it was
hopelessly conflicted, who was the
largest shareholder in Tesla at the time
of the deal? A guy called Elon Musk. Who
was the largest shareholder in Solar
City at the time of the deal? A guy
called Elon Musk. What a coincidence.
Same guy, right? Who was the CEO of
Tesla? A guy called Elon Musk. Who was
the CEO of Solar City? A guy called Musk
with a different first name. His
cousin. They emerged and they knew they
were going to get sued. So they wanted
to get
protection. So Solar City hires Lazard.
Lazard is an oldtime New York investment
bank to give a fairness opinion. Tesla
hires
Evercore. It's a boutique investment
bank. You think what's a boutique
investment bank? It's like a gastrop
pub. You know what a gastrop pub is? You
walk by them in the airport, never go
in. A gastropub is just a burger joint
where they triple the price. They call
it gastrop pub, right? They're kind of
fancy name. So boutique investment bank
just does what investment banks do but
they charge you three times the
price. So both sides go to play. Lazard
does the typical banking things to
justify it. What are the typical banking
things? Apply a terminal multiple do a
little dance but none of it was you know
uncommon. So I said we're doing the
typical banking thing. But then I looked
at the Evercore valuation of Tesla
because it was an exchange offer. They
had to value both companies. So Everore
actually had to value Tesla and it is in
my view the worst discounted cash flow
valuation I've ever seen in my life. You
know how tough that is as a contest to
win. So here's what they did. They took
Tesla and they projected out five years
of cash flows. They did the Kabuki out
capex depreciation working capital FCF.
They might not even have the
FCF. At the end of five years they get
tired. So what do they do? They estimate
a terminal value. I guess they didn't
feel the need to use
multiples. They decide to use a growth
rate in perpetuity saying this is good.
They made the right choice. The only
problem is they used a 6% growth rate
forever. My first reaction is what
currency you valuing the company maybe
Argentine pesos. And you forgot to tell
me a 6% growth rate forever at a time
when the economy was growing 3% a
year. Work out the math, right? Sooner
or later, what's going to happen? Tesla
is going to become the US economy. Okay,
globalization. Keep going. 20 years
later, it'll be the global economy. Then
what? Now SpaceX has to enter the story
and Mars has to get
populated because there's no way out of
the
story. This was
nonsensical. And for this piece of crap,
you know how much Everco got
paid?
$8.5 million.
There's no justice in this
world,
right? I actually I gave the talk at
Everore and actually in the bank in the
elevator. I was with the three bankers
who did the deal and I told them and
this I don't know how you guys ever put
your names. You will live in infamy for
what you've done. I will make sure you
live in infamy because I've saved the
document. I've written about it in real
time. So that post I I'll send to you
because I also sent seven questions to
the Delaware court judges as as
suggestions that they should ask
bankers on the next time a fairness
opinion came in impossible
valuation. I've seen people make
assumptions about growth and you can
grow obviously but one of my favorites
was about 10 years ago somebody valued
Netflix. Netflix is always one of the
most widely picked stocks in this class
to value valued Netflix. Middle of the
semester like you, I give them a
one-time chance to get feedback. I look
at the Netflix valuation and he's got a
value four times stock price. I'm
surprised there's a company that's
really tough to get close to fairly
valued, four times the price. So, I take
a look at his assumptions and he has
revenues of $600 billion in your tent.
So I emailed the guy and I said, "Can
you come into my office? I have some
questions to ask you." So there was So
he comes in, he said, "What's your
question?" I said, "I noticed you have
600 billion in revenues in year 10." He
said, "Do you have Netflix?" He said,
"Yes." He said, "How much do you pay per
year?" He said, "About $100 a year." I
said, "You got 600 billion revenue,
roughly a $100. How many subscribers
would Netflix need to have?" He put out
his calculator. They said, "You don't
need a calculator. 600 billion 100,
that's 6 billion people." He said, "I
don't see where this questioning is
going." I said, "Just hang in there. I
have a I have a couple more questions
and then you can leave." I said, "How
many people are there on the face of the
earth?" Said, "I don't know. I'll check
out Google." I said, "I'll save you the
trouble. It's about 8 billion. Is there
something you haven't told me? Maybe
there's been a law that's been passed
that every man, woman, child, and pet
has to have their own Netflix account
and they can't share. He said, "Don't be
absurd." I said, "I'm not the one
estimating 600 billion in revenues. You
are." And I said, "How do you come up
with this number?" He just he said, "I
just took last year's number and I
projected it out." He said, "What are
you talking about?" He said, "Last year
they had 30% growth. I just put it in
for the next 10
years. You created a fairy tale." Right?
Third, can you cut costs and improve
margins? Absolutely. And if you're an
inefficient company, I can give you
growth next year. You do it in year two.
I'm saying, okay, year three, but you
keep doing it forever, we have a
problem. You see why? You keep cutting
cost. Your margins keep going up. Your
margins hit 100%. Your costs have gone
to zero. There's nothing left to cut.
This is why you can't use cost cutting
as a rationale for terminal growth in
perpetuity.
And finally, there's a very technical
version of an impossible
valuation. Many banking valuations have
a depreciation line item and a capex
line items as separate line items. And
the the two will grow at different
rates. And if you're not careful,
depreciation will hit capex and keep
growing above the capex and in a sense
forever because you put into your
terminal cash flow. Can't happen because
if you don't capex it, it there's no
depreciation. Those are impossible
valuations. Let's talk about implausible
valuations. Implausible valuations can
happen, but you better have a really
good
story. So the first one, you have a
company that's growing without much in
reinvestment. How can that be? I'll give
you a good story. I'm an infrastructure
company. I've spent the last 20 years
building the infrastructure. I've just
opened it up for use. I'm going to get
growth, but I don't need reinvestment.
I'm a pharmaceutical company. I can get
growth without because my reinvestment
is seven 8 n years ago. I'm looking for
that story to justify. So if you give me
no notice evaluation in nova notice
where you give in 20% growth for the
next 5 years with very little R&D I can
see where that's coming from that WGO
and OMIC is continuing to feed into your
growth rate.
Or you have a company which makes high
margins much higher than everybody else
but there seems to be no competition
coming in. It's a farmer company. The
explanation is simple right? There's
patents. But what if it's not a farmer
company? You got to tell me a story as
to what keeps the competition out.
Remember valuing a company called Almar.
It's a Saudi food processing company.
Its margins were twice as high as
everybody else in the Middle East in
terms of food processing. Now it's
puzzled. How come no compet? So I
actually presented this in Dubai. There
were a few people from Saudi Arabia
there were familiar with the company and
one of them said you should check out
who the biggest shareholders in the
company are and I did. Second on the
list was somebody somebody bins SA part
of the Saudi route. There's your
competitive
advantage. You're looking for a good
story to explain this or you have a
company that makes high returns without
much risk.
Maybe it's politically connected. You
got a government contract. The
government is overpaying you, but
because of your connections, you can
continue to collect it. I'm looking for
a good story. And finally, I've
improbable valuations. To understand
improbable valuations, I'm going to
present one of my favorite devices for
deconstructing DCF. It's what I'm going
to use. I'm going to give away the game.
When you send me your valuations in
April 4, this is what I'm going to use
to kind of look at your valuations.
So re let's suppose you send me your
valuation on April 4th. I'm going to
assume you will. Let's start at the top
line. You got revenue growth, right? You
can have high revenue growth, average or
low revenue growth. Pick any
one. Low. Okay. So you have low revenue
growth. It's your story. I'm not going
to push back. See, but then I'm going to
go check your cash flows. There's
earnings and cash flow. That difference
is what you're reinvesting, right? So if
I saw low revenue growth, what should I
expect to see in reinvestment? low
reinvestment. I I should expect to see
low reinvestment. Then I check your cost
of capital. Generally speaking,
companies with low revenue growth and
low reinvestment should have lower than
average cost of capital because you're
probably in a boring business with low
growth. Low
low. In contrast, when Leon turns to his
valuation, there's going to be high
revenue growth. I don't know how high
because Reddit potentially everything is
in the future. But then when I look at
reinvestment, I want to see what they're
reinvesting to get that revenue growth.
And I would expect their cost of capital
to be higher than the typical company
because they're still in that growth
phase. And then an online advertising
company high high. I'm okay. About 80%
of your valuations will be either high
high low average average. But about 20%
of your valuation, one of those sides or
maybe two will be out of sync. You know
what I mean by out of sync? high revenue
growth, low margin, low reinvestment.
And then I'm going to look for your
story. So if you're doing Boeing and you
put in high growth, low reinvestment,
and low risk, somebody fill out the
story that'll explain that
combination. Where's the high growth
coming
from? The fact that there revenues last
year dropped to half the aircraft they
had 5 years ago. That maybe Airbus will
screw up on something really big and
then you'll come back. So the revenue
growth is a number of why don't they
need big reinvestment to do this because
they have huge excess capacity on their
plants and why is it low risk because
you're only two players in this
game high growth low re so I'm not
saying that's a story but you can see
that there's a story behind them so as
you look at these companies that's what
you're looking for so I told you my Uber
story I passed it through my own test is
it possible Yeah, definitely. It's a car
service company. Is it plausible? I can
justify it. Remember that story about
attracting new users. In 2014, Uber had
been in the Bay Area for 5 years already
and they doubled the size of the car
service business in the Bay Area. In
what sense? Cuz people were not buying
cars anymore. Uber lift was so
ubiquitous that they just
stopped. My story is possible,
plausible, probable. Could I have told a
bigger story? Yeah. So next session
we'll talk about what happens when you
make your story bigger. How the onus is
now on you to come up with the defense
that justifies it. So I will see you on
Monday.